it never hurts to plan ahead especially
when it comes to Hollywood's biggest
flicks from long-awaited sequels to an
animated musical reboot these are the
2025 movies worth making some room on
your calendar for originally intended
for release in November of 2024 Marvel
Studios Fantastic Four reboot has been
pushed back to February 14th 2025. the
long-awaited project is set to be one of
the first films of The mcu's Phase 6
which will also include two Avengers
films but more on that later in
September of 2022 deadline reported that
Jeff Kaplan and Ian Springer had been
brought on to write the screenplay for
the film with Matt Jackman directing
while Springer and Kaplan haven't had a
ton of high profile work go up in
Hollywood yet shackman is an experienced
TV director with episodes of Fargo Game
of Thrones and It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia on his resume he's worked
with Marvel Studios before having
directed an executive produced the first
Marvel Disney plus series one division
in 2021 few story details have been
released about the new Fantastic Four
but as always there are some Clues as to
what fans can expect for one Marvel
Studios president Kevin feige has
suggested that he wants to avoid a
traditional origin story considering how
many times the Fantastic Four has been
adapted for the big screen since the
turn of the century this is the story
that Kevin wants yeah okay then I want
to talk to Kevin
popular Fan cast John Krasinski has
already played version of Reed Richards
in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness but the actor has stated that he
isn't necessarily planning on returning
there was a time when the whole point of
an MCU movie was to help build up to a
new entry in The Avengers series but
ever since Iron Man snapped his fingers
and turned Thanos into dust back in 2019
that hasn't been the case by the time
Avengers the Kang Dynasty is released in
2025 currently scheduled for May 2nd the
MCU will have gone two entire phases
without an entry in The Avengers Saga
that should be enough to build plenty of
excitement for the series fifth
installment but there are plenty of
other reasons to look forward to it
Shang Chi and the legend of the ten
Rings director Destin Daniel is
set to direct the Kang Dynasty with Jeff
loveness writing the script loveness who
comes from a background writing for
comedy shows like Jimmy Kimmel Live and
Rick and Morty also penned the
screenplay for Ant-Man wasp quantumania
which brings Kang the Conqueror to the
MCU for the first time as such he seems
like a perfect choice to write Avengers
5 and it's likely that the phase 5 film
will set up a lot as of now all we know
about the Kang Dynasty is that it will
star the titular time traveling villain
who seems ready to usurp thanos's Throne
as the mcu's scariest antagonist the
comic run from which the film takes its
title may offer some clues in it Kang
successfully takes over the entire world
bringing unparalleled destruction and
Terror along the way the Avengers will
definitely have their hands full in
phase six see you soon
the All-Star horror movie team of James
Juan Jason Blum and akayla Cooper United
to release Megan in early 2023 a
surprise hit about a young girl's
robotic companion who turns murderous
directed by Gerard Johnstone the film
grossed nearly 175 million dollars at
the global box office on a budget of
just 12 million dollars sparking rumors
of a sequel that has since been
confirmed according to deadline Megan
2.0 is planned for release on January 17
2025. original Stars Allison Williams
and violet McGraw are both set to return
with Williams stepping into a full
producer role as well in an interview
with New Zealand's 1 news John Stone
said he's in talks to return as director
while we don't have any leads on story
details yet it's not hard to imagine
where Megan 2.0 might go the first film
ends on a Victorious but ominous note
that ensures viewers know that the
titular Megan is far from dead given the
Sci-Fi trappings of the franchise there
are any number of ways she could return
bigger scarier and deadlier Cooper
returns to pen the script while both
Blum and Juan are set to act as
producers which means that it's safe to
assume that the sequel will have the
same overall feel as the original in an
interview with collider Juan said he
already has ideas for a bigger world for
the series could this be the start of
the next hit horror franchise only time
will tell in early 2021 fans of avatar
The Last Airbender rejoiced at the
announcement of Avatar Studios a new
division of Paramount plus and
Nickelodeon fully focused on developing
the Beloved franchise original series
creators Brian konitzko and Michael
Dante demartino will serve as Chief
creative officers for the Studio's first
animated film intended for theatrical
release over a year later Nickelodeon
teased through Avatar Korra voice actor
Janet Varney that the film would follow
Avatar Aang and his friends in November
of 2022 a release date of October 10th
2025 5 was announced no other story
details have been confirmed but given
the recent history of the Avatar
franchise we can assume a few things the
official comics from Dark Horse take
place in the immediate aftermath of the
original Show's finale and it seems
unlikely that the movie the franchise's
triumphant return to animation would
simply recycle those stories plus the
original voice cast is grown up now and
zactyler Eisen the actor behind Aang
doesn't really do voiceover work anymore
for these reasons it might make more
sense for the film to follow adult
versions of the avatar the lost
airbender characters with either new
voice actors or the ones used for
flashbacks in The Legend of Korra well
that's just silly I don't sound like
that
oh man this Ranger's a genius either way
the film definitely sounds promising in
addition to kinesco Andy Martino long
time franchise director Lauren
Montgomery is helming the project and
The Versatile Australian Animation
Studio flying bark Productions will
produce hopefully things go better than
the last time Aang and his friends hit
Cinemas the past few years have been
rough for Star Wars on the big screen
after the lackluster responses to solo a
Star Wars story and Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker Disney officially declared
a Hiatus on its planned slate of future
films deciding to focus instead on
building out the franchise on Disney
Plus instead for a Time Star Wars was
set to return to theaters in 2023 with
Patty Jenkins Rogue Squadron movie
looking like the likely choice however
Jenkins film has been temporarily
derailed with lucasfilm President
Kathleen Kennedy telling Vanity Fair in
2022 that it was undergoing rewrites as
of now a Star Wars movie is still slated
for release in December of 2025 but it's
hard to predict what it will be numerous
projects have been rumored over the past
few years including potential films from
taikua TD stranger things producer Sean
Levy and Star Trek Into Darkness writer
Damon Lindelof a story from The
Hollywood Reporter in October of 2022
claimed that lindelof's film may be the
next one up in 2025 and that a writer's
room has already assembled at lucasfilm
to work on ideas it's clear that Disney
is experimenting with many different
ideas which makes it hard to predict
what we'll get next at the very least
lucasfilm doesn't seem to be lacking
ideas Kennedy told total film in 2022
that she wants to create a whole new
saga and there have been reports of both
a Knights of the Old Republic project
and more movies set in the sequel era
whatever happens the return of Star Wars
to the big screen is an exciting
prospect for fans it may feel strange if
you grew up watching SpongeBob
SquarePants on Nickelodeon but the
animated undersea comedy franchise is
now nearly as prolific on the big green
as the small the series first made its
way to theaters with 2004's the
SpongeBob SquarePants movie which
carried the same core animation style as
the show over a decade passed before the
next big screen outing 2015's the
SpongeBob Movie sponge Out of Water
which became a huge success the
SpongeBob Movie sponge on the Run
followed in 2020 and another film in the
modern 3D style has been announced for
May 23 2025. Nickelodeon hasn't revealed
any real details of what the story will
entail and with the franchise now more
expansive than ever the possibilities
are endless SpongeBob SquarePants has
become a major IP asset for Paramount in
the company's modern hybrid release ERA
with the movie supplementing multiple
series across both traditional
television and streaming Distribution on
Paramount plus it could even be said
that the studio is overloaded with
SpongeBob SquarePants content but it
still shows no signs of slowing down
Sponge Out of Water was a box office hit
and received strong reviews but sponge
on the run was met with a much more
lukewarm reception a few years later oh
no
it's it's not over yet
to be seen if the third film of this
modern series will continue a decline or
return to the franchise's former peaks
with some luck it'll be the latter a
quiet place has become one of the
biggest surprises in recent movie
history growing from a one-off horror
movie made on a 17 million dollar budget
to a blockbuster franchise the creative
collaboration between real-life couple
John Krasinski and Emily Blunt was a
standout hit and a spin-off film set
before the events of the original is set
for release in 2024. those who want the
proper conclusion to the story of the
Abbott family however we'll have to wait
until 2025. blonde has been open for
some time about the original story being
intended as the trilogy which suggests
that a quiet place part 3 will wrap up
the major character arcs that began in
2018. in early 2022 Krasinski declared a
2025 release for the three cool
presumably he'll be directing once again
with a full-on prequel set to release
before a quiet place part 3 comes out
there could be a lot of new elements
added to the hit horror Saga that should
make the eventual conclusion even more
exciting but for now details are being
kept Under Wraps after a somewhat
confused period for the cape Crusaders
film career following Christopher
Nolan's The Dark Knight trilogy director
Matt Reeves and star Robert Pattinson
returned Bruce Wayne to his former glory
with the Batman the 2022 film received
excellent reviews and performed well at
the box office succeeding on the merits
of its gritty Noir inspired tone and
Stellar production design it wasn't long
before a proper sequel was announced
with Pattinson and Reeves both returning
along with project power writer Matson
Tomlin on scripting Duty the film is set
to release on October 3rd 2025. the
Batman has already done an excellent job
of building out a distinct version of
Gotham City and it's easy to imagine all
kinds of directions in which the sequel
could go Pattinson himself told den of
geek in 2022 that he'd be interested in
a version of the popular court of owls
storyline while Reeves has expressed
interest in a grounded version of Mr
Freeze it's also likely that Barry
keogan's Joker who debuted at the end of
the Batman could play a major role
there's even the possibility that we
haven't yet Seen the Last of Paul Dano's
Riddler and you know
Gotham loves a comeback story Gotham
City has a nearly endless Trove of bad
guys to pull from and Reeves has proved
himself a very competent filmmaker with
both the Batman and other projects like
the Latter-Day Planet of the Apes movies
wherever his team decides to take the
story it should be exciting to watch The
Smurfs haven't had the steadiest track
record at the Modern box office with
Sony Pictures 2010's film series
receiving poor reviews throughout its
run in 2022 it was announced that
Nickelodeon and Paramount would be
putting their own spin on the classic
franchise with an animated musical film
scheduled for release in 2024. that date
was later pushed to February 14 2025 to
make room for Sonic the Hedgehog 3. as
you might expect the upcoming reboot is
intended to be a family film with plenty
of cartoon Whimsy and musical charm
Chris Miller has been tapped to direct
the picture he's quite experienced in
the genre having previously helmed the
Dreamworks Animation features track the
third and boots there's been
little in the way of official casting
news but it seems safe to assume that
the new Smurfs film will follow the
modern Hollywood trend of casting an
ensemble of recognizable stars to play
the various roles hopefully Paramount
can finally do the brand Justice and
properly relaunch The Smurfs for a new
generation the Tron franchise is one of
Disney's oddest the original 1982 film
wasn't exactly a box office smash but it
developed a cult appeal thanks to its
groundbreaking CGI effects a rare sight
at the time a sequel Tron legacy
followed in 2010 but momentum stalled on
any further development of the franchise
now a third film currently going by the
name of Tron Ares is finally back on the
books with Jared Leto set to Star and
Joachim roaning directing the movie is
currently expected on December 19th
2025. under ronin's Direction it could
be quite a spectacle the filmmaker is no
stranger to the contempt Prairie live
action Disney blockbuster machine having
previously helmed films like Pirates of
the Caribbean Dead Men tell no tales in
2017 and Maleficent Mistress of evil in
2019. Leto may be less of a sure thing
as he has developed a reputation for box
office bombs in addition to his
questionable onset Behavior regardless a
return to the digital grid of Tron with
today's advancements in computer
animation technology is an exciting idea
the series has always been more about a
certain look and feel than a
hard-hitting narrative and it's likely
that this trend will continue into the
future maybe Disney can even get Daft
Punk back together to do the soundtrack
again but we're not getting our hopes up
that high this is going to be quite awry
[Music]